I'm Scott hey Jack I'm talking to you
about as a data scientist in a
experience that I had collaborating with
an application development team and the
learnings that came out of that to make
that as efficient and positive a
collaboration as possible
so I'm gonna after briefly telling you a
little more about myself I'm gonna talk
to you about how part of the solution to
this question collaboration was a data
science API why that was a good thing
and what contract testing is and what
why that was also part important part of
making that collaboration successful and
how in particular our way of solving
that problem was something called JSON
schema and how to use it in your testing
and then also to use it to give better
error messages so like most data
scientists and superheroes I have a
backstory and an origin story that's not
wasn't data science so so initially I
was doing psycholinguistics and
phonetics research but in the last five
years I've been in the New York area
focusing on machine learning and
software development and then I work for
a pivotal software which if you're not
familiar with it they they have both
products and services and their products
include platforms for distributed data
and applications so if you've heard of
Cloud Foundry or as a application
platform or greenplum database for
example as a distributed data platform
those are examples and then on the
services side we have data science and
we have agile software development and
you know a lot of times we might be
engagements where it's just data science
or just agile software development and
they're you know they can be very quick
so we have to we go in and do some great
stuff in shorts amount of short amounts
of time like three months or so but in
this the inspiration for this talk came
from a case where it was actually a
joint engagement so as a balance team
with with data science and software
developments and and it also
you know I got excited about
incorporating data science directly into
what's being actually used in
applications so that and that first
experience with this was you know
brought about the question how do we
actually collaborate you know I
definitely heard of an experience before
the you know doing some toy modeling and
proving something out and then throwing
the everything over the wall and then
having some other team reimplemented
most of it incorrectly and being a
nightmare but in this case where we
wanted to be cohesive but at the same
time you know agile software development
is not the same as agile data science
you know our iteration cycles are
different and a lot of about our process
might not quite aligned so we want the
independence between our teams and loose
coupling between the components and most
of all we didn't want to break each
other's code and and that had been a
problem and specifically you know this
project I'm not going to focus on the
ins and outs of the specific data
science problem that were solving but
just know that it was the the problem
space is manufacturing and a large
manufacturer needing to optimize how
they commit to and deliver the their
their product manufacturing schedule and
then they wanted an application for the
people who have to make those decisions
to make recommendations so the
application development team for a
variety of reasons of the business were
required to write their stuff in c-sharp
and then I started racking my brains
like okay what I know about data science
in c-sharp the answer was nothing but I
have a lot of experience doing in Python
and so our way of forging forward was to
do two separate micro services and you
know to two services and we would and
and I'll talk more about this but we
would provide an a restful api for them
to send requests to most of you probably
know but api is an application
programming interface and how i just
drive it is that if you have a resource
that you want others to be able to
programmatically
use then then that interface is an API
and at least in my mind there kind of a
spectrum or different ways of thinking
about it you could have it just be a
library or package like scikit-learn
where you know I'm I'm going to use it
but it's within the same language
probably even on the same machine you
know that I'm doing or on the other end
you could have a restful web service
like you know Google vision API is or
you know variety of all the api's we
hear about and then in those cases it's
these HTTP POST and get requests that
are sent over and you get answers back
so what in our case you know like so
what what would it be good what would
success for our team look like or in
general with an API in it you know
obviously something needs to be useful
otherwise you know why have it why use
it at all but at the same time it needs
to be useful without necessarily needing
to open the black box that's not to say
that that it should be closed source and
and they're not allowed to look at what
you have but they shouldn't have to rely
on it in order for it to be useful and
so let's let's envision an API that is
quiz show clue answering service and so
you know speaking of how things are
implemented you know Ken Jennings and
IBM Watson are implemented extremely
differently but the the same expectation
is that that alex trebek should be able
to provide a clue and get an answer in
the appropriate format whether that's
right or not it's another question but
the so here it is so after a
demonstration of this the April 8 1927
New York Times said commercial use in
doubt no no no no no don't don't don't
don't know and he guesses what's a
computer
what's the television
so importantly you know in jeopardy the
clues always have to be as a statement
and the responses have to be as a
question
so if Alex Trebek had asked it turned
this statement into a question it would
have broken the expectation of of the
participants and also if they had
responded just television or it is the
television that would not have been
counted as a correct answer so a
light-hearted view of an interface and
why form matters you know scikit-learn
I'm sure everyone uses and loves and one
of the things that makes it great is
that reliable interface you give it you
instantiated classifier you fit you have
gotten fit methods to and data in a
certain kind of format you get a train
model you take a train model you can do
predict probability and as long as your
new data has the same you know shape as
the input training data then you get
quest probabilities or if it's or if
it's regression then you know you can do
dot predict and get predicted value so
now the important thing with
scikit-learn is that you know it's
you're meant to you know keep track of
what your matrix looks like and and so
at the level of scikit-learn it doesn't
care about column names or row names or
any other metadata but you know so this
you know is playing around with the
Boston housing data set and so you know
some of the columns are crime rate
percent residential percent business
percent or you know whether it's a
waterfront property but if all you had
is that matrix it could just as well be
at the percent on times which on time
trains which in New York is visible the
square foot of your bathroom which is
also a kind of small or negligent the
average chocolate price which drives a
lot of my decisions and whether or not
they allow dogs which also drives my
decision because I like my dog so you
know you don't know just from looking at
the data so self-describing formats
that's one thing that I learned you know
at first I tried just giving them you
know like matrices lists and whatnot and
that didn't go over so well so they want
something more self describing you know
so dicts with keys with meaningful you
know that the keys
the data are you're passing it into the
prediction function and giving something
back and you know again with you know
self-describing format the other thing
that I learned is that you don't
necessarily want to give just the like
just the data portion you always want to
leave yourself some room to attack on
some metadata and have some room to grow
and then you'd have to few make fewer
changes later down the line so you know
added this you know request type and
response type and then the data is just
a one about you keep value in there but
this is the contract so this is you know
at first I mocked up an example of input
data and an example of output data and
then I gave it to the other app dev team
and then said okay like my stuff is
going to look like this and so that's
the contract if you give me something on
the Left I'll give you something like on
the right but you know it turns out that
just an example might not be sufficient
you know like you gave a number that
looks like a float but can you sometimes
it be passing an integer or vice versa
and so forth or can it be null and
things like that
so you know so contract testing and also
if you also if you you know if you say
this but just leave it on your shared
drive and then never reference it in
your then you could vary from from that
contract without knowing it so testing
is what ensured that we stayed in sync
it gave us that independence to do our
own thing like as soon as we got the API
set up then they got to go on the do on
the their own thing and at first we just
gave some dummy responses and that was
great so just give us a breathing room
it also gave us the the power to
refactor with confidence so that you
know once you start getting really
complex you change you're worried about
Oda if I change this code over here
you know maybe I want to clean this up
is it going to break my how I'm
interacting with everyone else this
ensures that it doesn't and also
I can give better error messages because
initially if anything wrong in our app
happened including if they gave us bad
input they would just get a 500 error
which is you know this generically
something on this application went wrong
which is not so useful because they
don't know if it's a problem on our end
or if they gave that input so all right
so let's do contract testing let's let's
do this so my first thought was okay if
I have some canned input and know what
it's supposed to give for output and
some canned output then I'll check my
actual output against the canned output
and and then we're good to go like maybe
even exact string strings match wait a
minute
geez and in sort of objects in JSON or
or in dictionaries could be in different
orders but it's still technically the
same thing okay that doesn't work okay
let's encode special numbers like I know
that I am my prediction is going to be
like a food a hundred thousand dollars
is gonna be the price for this one input
but actually you know as the data
science has actually hoped that my model
would change over time and get better so
it's not gonna always be the same values
so it makes it very brittle if you do it
that way or you might add or subtract
metadata and things won't pass so our
answer to this and I was very grateful
for learning from the seasoned software
developers was JSON schema which is a
way to make clear and explicit what
you're expecting as input and to give us
output and you can use it directly in
testing and as well as the people
consuming your API can use that same
schema and their contract tests and so
JSON schema is a specification for
annotating and validating JSON documents
and so it itself is written in JSON and
there are validators that exist for a
variety of languages so actually that's
part of where the power comes in because
they were doing their stuff in c-sharp
me and python but this same contract
this same schema we could both use
directly so there's one point of
reference and they're both are you know
validators work on both ends we're good
to go
so just to give you a taste of JSON
schema if you're not familiar with it so
let's say we have a JSON about a person
oh let me pause just a second I meant to
say in the beginning if there's ever
question along the way I'm happy to take
questions mid-stride as well so if
there's a JSON describing a person and
we have John who's 30 years old not
married and likes apple and kiwi a
schema might look something like this
where there's a you know the overall
object is in what's called an object
that's a you know from Jason from
JavaScript no terminology and then it
has these name age married properties
and it tells what types they are and
then even for the favorite fruits it
says you know that's an array but the
things inside it are our strings just as
a note though by default these are all
optional so if you so this is good but
so is an empty object and so is adding
additional fields now depending on what
you're doing that mayor and that may not
be good behavior that you want and so
what you can do is there are also ways
of saying required properties or the
additional properties are not allowed
and/or that those name and age for
example are required and so that way you
can start constraining things which is
is good the other thing you couldn't
even do is go even further and say well
age can be it has to be an integer but
it also needs to be between 0 and 200 so
that they don't give you negative
numbers or like a million I'm being
generous 200 because you know I don't
want to put it too low because medicine
is advancing at a rapid pace
so the other thing is I thought about ok
what if your nesting complex objects
when within each other so siblings are
so this is a person object a sibling is
a person too so you know I should be
able to say that that one of the
properties is siblings and it's an array
but it's an array of type person so
there's a lot of power
and complexity can build in and again
I'm not focusing on the use case that I
was working with but with this
optimization problem and the the complex
business domain logic and the all the
constraints that they had you know the
the business domain was very complex and
therefore all of the inputs had to be
very complex and so that's especially
when JSON schema came to our rescue
because any other simpler you know even
if you're using good testing practices
but it gets it gets gnarly so other
things that are available as ways of
constraining
the the schema is you can look for
specific values you can look for you
know their size of the array you can
have conditional or boolean logic you
can define have defined formats like
date and time email addresses and
regular expressions and so forth and
there's there's a lot more it's a very
powerful standard so going into this I
actually didn't even know a quarter of
all this when I actually when they told
me about it and before I started
benefiting from it what I did at first
is I said okay there's this thing called
JSON schema go to the go to quicktype
and use this tool so you drop in JSON
and you can get a schema out and it's
kind of generic there aren't maybe quite
as many constraints as you'd want but
it's a great starting point and there's
even options for instead of outputting
JSON you can tell it to give you the
Python code for parsing that JSON even
if it's these complex objects with what
end up being different classes and all
of that and and so the other thing
that's important for me is because a lot
of times my you know the data is
sensitive and so I'd like to use some
real data as the example to make sure
it's you know in generating the schema
but at the same time I'm not allowed to
do anything that sends the data to some
random whoever runs this quick type
application on the internet so two
things one is that the the maintainer
zuv this claim that it's all just in the
local client JavaScript code that it
doesn't send the data anywhere the other
thing is that there's a command line too
that you could turn off your internet if
you're really paranoid and do it that
way so this is just a view of what the
interface ends up looking like and when
I dropped in my examples JSON and on the
and the important thing is you have to
select you know what you want to give it
as input and how you want it out on the
right so you can see on the right it it
fills in some of the boilerplate and
then it'll even do some smart
assumptions like it's cut off here but
the data key is then an array of type
type datum so it even smartly figures
okay if you're you know the naming and
all of that it figures okay then I'm
gonna make a separate subclass and sub
definition for all of those elements so
moving on like that that's to give a
flavor of the power this so and and I
said that one of the keys was to be able
to incorporate this into tests and so
testing is is super simple there's a
JSON schema package in Python and so you
can use any test framework you want but
the key is that two things to let you
know it has to be the parts to JSON so
it's not just the raw JSON string that
this library requires as input so it's
you know you json dot load the other
thing is that then you just take in this
case I imported whatever my predict
function is that takes that good request
that I have as an example and then I get
the response and then and then I have
then there's JSON schema dot validate
giving the instance first and then the
response schema on the right and if it
if it's correct it it's like a no
operation but if it fails it raises an
exception a validation error and that's
how you test on it and so the benefit
from all this is that you your there's a
lot of benefits aside from hopefully
breaking each other's code less often
but there's also the opportunity for you
know a be testing becomes easier because
as soon as you have a very solid
contract then swapping out
implementations is super easy in terms
of you know like if you have you know
someone goes to a website and it's
randomly decided which which version of
the API to call but it's that the call
is the same and the what they're getting
back is the same so a/b testing becomes
easier more robust also if you want to
do test-driven development which is
something that on the application
development side at pivotal they really
focus on or that's where you even before
you start writing the code you you write
your tests and then just do whatever it
takes to get those tests pass and then
refactor so that's a possibility doesn't
always make sense for data science but
it's really it was fun the times I've
tried it fun and useful and then most
importantly there's continuous
integration which if you're not familiar
with that that's just a way that if you
have a way of deploying your code and
you have test Suites then when you push
your codes then it automatically runs
all the tests and if they all pass then
they can be pushed into you know
actually use and if not then it catches
it before it gets pushed out all kinds
of benefits that came from that and then
the last one that I'm gonna speak to is
giving better error messages so for
example if I have a bad request and then
my request schema I gave it you know
throws this validation error and then it
gives a very specific information that I
had given 2.31 actually as a string
instead of a float or a number and and
so it gives that really specific
information and where in the object and
where in the schema it broke now one
note about that is that this validation
throws it throws on the first wrong
thing what I found to be useful was that
maybe they actually made more than one
mistake in the request so they want to
know what they would want to know what
all of them are so just as an example
how to enumerate all those then you you
instantiate a
from the json schema schema draft
validator and then not and then with
that you can iterators and so then that
way you're getting all that information
you can build and some kind of error
message to to pass back to them as part
of the response just so to recap
approaching this collaboration with
application development side of things
was really helped by having a data
science API it helped us be
simultaneously independent but also
staying in lock steps being cohesive the
contract testing is is a way to actually
ensure that and give you some clarity
and confidence in doing so and in
particular you know there might there's
I'm sure there are plenty of other tools
but I found JSON schema to be a pretty
lightweight way for a data scientist to
achieve all this without you know going
too far off the deep end for all the
other fancy stuff that software
developers do and because it's explicit
its standardized and there's tooling
around it to test with it it's as simple
as you know installing it and validate
method and and as I mentioned you can
iterate through all the errors and give
really good error messages and be as
useful part of that collaboration as
soon as you can
I've made a few notes the the thinking
about things in terms of magic numbers
and avoiding them is something that some
ideas from some of my colleagues and
also other colleagues have talked about
an API first approach for data science
and some links to other the tools that I
mentioned and this and the
specifications I'm eager to you know get
in touch with anyone if anyone wants to
follow up they can follow up through
twitter and you know thank you very much
for your attention thank you
[Applause]
yeah okay I'll leave that here any any
questions or comments do we pass around
a mic er that's okay yeah that's that is
interesting because it the magic number
approach it first sounds good because
you're simultaneously somewhat testing
that you know the the right shape of
things at the same time as testing
testing the actual response but it turns
out that then one thing I learned from
from those software engineering
colleagues is that then you're testing
two things at once and then as soon as
you want to change how or what you're
testing and either one of those then you
have to change all of it and so it's
actually you may have heard you know
phrases like separation of concerns and
all that kind of thing you know the same
goes with testing so if you so in saying
to use JSON schema I'm not recommending
that as a replacement for having other
tests that says specifically you know
that that you know your output
you know JSON schema is not going to
tell you if that was the actual optimal
output you need other tests to do that
but it should be other tests it
shouldn't be the same one and it makes
life a lot easier
any other questions so so it sounds like
you fell in love with JSON did you
consider engineer any other data formats
and rejected them me no in this case I
it was you know it's something that I
knew about and the developers obviously
knew about I mean there's things that I
know of but would never consider it is
like XML because yeah and there are
validators for XML as well but but you
know it's it's it's so much more verbose
and it's not you know friendly on the
eyes even though this is all an
automated you know process and it
doesn't have to be friendly on the eyes
but if you want to peek at things it's
more helpful but on the other end
there's like yeah Mille which is even
more human readable but then and they're
pretty good you know they're good
parsers for it out there and all that
but so that was in my mind the happy
medium of having something that's pretty
human readable but you know but but very
systematic
and actually you know so this is just
one you know JSON schema is just one way
of trying to tackle this problem but I'm
kind of curious if anyone out here has
tackled it in a different way and found
that useful
another you know buzzword that you might
hear from software developers are these
whole frameworks like swagger or other
kinds of things and you know I know very
little about them but after just some
quick googling it looks like they
support things like JSON schema so like
you know that's another benefit of
choosing something where there's a lot
of tooling around it and so you know
even if they are using some really high
power tooling that you yourself may not
use but then at least you have this like
contract between you that that you can
understand yeah
class or yeah yeah so it was a flask app
and and we were using cloud foundry
which is it's it's a platform for easily
deploying applications and also making
it easy for multiple applications to
talk to each other and so actually
that's also another technology and that
made it really easy to deploy like even
I was knew how to push the application
and so that broke down some barriers of
of needing to go through some operations
person each time I wanted to make a
change and the other cool thing was that
you know I could make this push and
actually you know the very first
iteration of the model was pretty much a
dummy model and and kind of garbage off
the you know non optimal values but then
as it got better I would just you know
push those changes and they didn't have
to change anything on their side it's
just what was showing up in the app was
just better the results
great well thank you all for your time
and I look forward to the rest of the
conference with you
[Applause]